i would be remiss if i did not get to
what is easily the stupidest story of
the day this is the stupidest story of
the day
this is from the wellness section at the
washington post so
you may recall that there is a woman who
is stupid enough to put a bunch of
gorilla glue in her hair
this is very stupid gorilla glue is glue
as indicated by the name gorilla glue
right it is super glue essentially why
would you put that in your hair
unless you're a dum-dum okay the ladies
dum-dum
as evidenced by the fact that you put
glue in her hair i don't even have to go
further than that you take gorilla glue
and you spray it in your hair
yay you ain't getting into phi beta
capita hey
how does the washington post spin this
well it turns out that the lady was
black
i had no idea but apparently she is
this means that the reason she sprayed
gorilla glue in her hair i'm not kidding
you
the reason she sprayed gorilla glue in
her hair is because of systemic racism
according to the washington post which
is weird because i have not seen a
massive spate of black people spraying
gorilla glue into their hair only this
dumb lady
like this is not a systemic problem in
the black community people spray
painting their hair with gorilla glue
like that's not a thing the reason this
lady was a headline is because she did
something unbelievably stupid
and then it went viral online and the
washington post was like yes but have
you considered the possibility that this
is an outgrowth of
400 years of oppression i know i didn't
consider that possibility because
oppressed people
generally don't spray gorilla glue in
their hair
weird but here is the washington post
our media they don't have a narrative
guys they are perfectly objective
remember this is not in the op-ed
section
leticia beach i'm writing jessica brown
no longer feels like she has red ants
crawling around her skull
scalp brown 40 nicknamed gorilla glue
girl
captured the internet's attention with
her forever ponytail after she used
gorilla glue spray
a very strong adhesive for heavy duty
project to create possibly the slickest
of side parts and swooped edges
known to womankind the embarrassing
ordeal has left brown with some missing
baby hairs bald patches that are
expected to recover and a much shorter
hairstyle that's nowhere near the amount
of inches she had with her month-long
braid
over the next six weeks brown can't put
put much else on her scalp except for a
concoction
created by a beverly hills
california-based plastic surgeon who
removed the glue from her hair
at this point i'm scared to put a
relaxer on my hair she told the
washington post in an interview adding
she has decided to go natural and
embrace the naturalness of her hair
brown saga says the washington post
which first went viral on social media
and then became national news
appealed to some black people who still
shudder at the thought of a relaxer or
the sizzling pain of a hot calm that got
too close to skin
memories that have led many black women
to sport their own kinks and curls
plenty of people ridiculed and got their
belly laughs at brown's misfortune but
there was a sense of community among
others
especially black people who sought to
shield her from being a spectacle of
idiocy
the extreme she went to for zero
flyaways is very unusual
but the desired outcome is as old as
black people's time in a country that
often mocks how they look
experts say
what now huh
so i use expressvpn because i want my
data protected i don't want hackers
getting my data i don't want big tech to
have my data that's why i use express
vpn expressvpn it's an app for your
computer and phone it secures and
encrypts your data so you can have peace
of mind every time you go online they
build a secure tunnel between your
devices and the internet
by re-routing your connection through
their servers that way your ip address
gets masked and your network data
becomes encrypted
so your isp can't see anything you do
the app connects with just
one click let me show you this magic you
see here it is oink
and there it is it's connecting check it
out connected and now i am protected
it's lightning fast
it's the only vpn i trust because they
use a trusted server find out how you
can get three months of expressvpn for
free by visiting expressvpn.com
shapiro or clicking the link in the
description box below so you want to
talk about the history of people
discriminating on the basis of race and
you want to talk about the
the discriminatory attitude towards
particular types of hair that have
existed in american society
perfectly fine if you want to say that
this lady is like a perfect example
of discrimination on the basis of hair
because she used gorilla glue in her
hair
again can't we just say that some people
are idiots and do stupid things is that
possible can we do that
is that ever a possibility why you would
lump in people
who want to wear their hair a certain
way with gorilla glue lady
or suggest that american society is to
blame for a dummy putting gorilla glue
on her head
is be i mean it's not beyond me i know
exactly why they're doing it right it's
every problem in american society is
attributable to systems of power those
systems of power
are rooted in innate white supremacy so
if a dumb lady puts gorilla glue on her
head and she happens to be a black lady
who put
glue on her head it has to be that this
is a legacy of america's hierarchies of
power
coming all the way back to 1619 think
peace in the new york times
this one at least is in the washington
post the mother of five said she was
familiar with gorilla glue before her
very unfortunate mistake
often using it around her louisiana home
for tasks such as setting up christmas
decorations okay first of all
that right there would be a good
indicator that she has a complete
it's not as though she went to the store
and she's like oh it says gorilla glue
and it's a spray so maybe it's a hair
spray
she used it around her home to glue
things and then she put it in her hair
okay this is the equivalent of the lady
who gave fish tank cleaner to her
husband
because she thought that fish tank
cleaner was hydroxychloroquine
people doing dumb things are usually not
outgrowths of systemic racism they're
just people doing dumb things
when she ran out of her favorite got to
be glued hairspray she reached for the
gorilla spray adhesive to save on time
before leaving her home
she figured she could just spray it on
her hair and wash it out once she got
home that day i don't know why you'd
figure that unless you're a dummy unless
you're stupid
days turned into a week before she
shamefully admitted to her mother what
she had done
that week became a month before she went
to social media to seek help she said
i'm sorry the fact that she was like
sitting around for a month and she's
like i uh my hair is
glued like after two days you weren't
like this is kind of a problem
she said the only reason why i took it
to social media is because we ran out of
things to do
i figured somebody out there would be
able to tell me what to do i never
thought my little girl would say my your
video has a million views
shanna console one of her young
daughters who said she endured taunts
from other children making fun
of her mother don't make fun of kids i
mean it's not the kid's fault that mommy
is
is not particularly bright brown had to
keep under control the angst of possibly
never running her fingers through her
hair again for the sake of the children
who came to her daycare tessa's little
angels learning academy
neil lester said he initially thought
brown's problem was a prank but as he
continued to follow this story he said
it reminded him of all the ways black
americans have used unusual hair
products to manipulate or style their
hair
i thought of malcolm x and his
experience with the conch said
foundation professor of english and
founding director of project of
humanities at arizona's arizona state
university
referring to the hair straightener made
of lye eggs and potatoes used by many
black people in the earlier
and middle part of the 20th century that
stringing started with enslaved people
using axle wheel grease
and dirty dishwasher with oil enslaved
men used axle wheel greases and means to
dye their hair or temporarily straighten
it
women would use butter fat from bacon or
grease from geese to care for their hair
according to hair story
untangling the roots of black hair in
america
uh yeah that's it
well see
she's not enslaved she
was not attempting to according to her
abide by
white standards of beauty or anything
she doesn't there's nothing in here that
says that that's what she was attempting
to do
she said she just liked her hair that
way but it's still systemic racism
so as always the root of every problem
in life is systemic american racism the
only solution
hire ibramex kendrick for twenty
thousand dollars to tell you that you're
a white supremacist
otherwise this sort of evil will run
rampant across society people gorilla
glueing their hair
every single day as a direct outgrowth
of the legacy of racism in the united
states
oh washington post i can't imagine why
people mistrust our institutional media
they're so good at what they do
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content